salut aujourd'hui je vous fais cette
vidéo depuis les loges de villars où je
joue mon spectacle ce soir et ça résonne
beaucoup trop au genre d'endroit
voilà ici ça devrait - raisonnée et en
plus avec les lumières qui donne sur le
public vous allez me voir depuis ce
début d'année j'ai donc lancé deux
nouveaux formats le bout ce brain quand
j'ai un invité pour vous apprendre
quelque chose mais lui aussi après le
faire en même temps et comme ça ça vous
motive et le mental expérience on en a
lancé vous est pour l'instant plus de 30
mille à avoir répondu il ya quatre
personnes spécialisées dans les
mathématiques qui sont en train
d'analyser les données brutes et je
préfère qu'on ne prenne le temps et
qu'on est une super analyse de tout ça
le format je vous présente aujourd'hui
s'appelle le hac life dans ce format là
je devrais toujours des astuces avec
votre mental que ce soit du mentalisme
du non verbal des choses pour simplifier
sa vie c'est le hac life qu'on me pose
souvent la question où est ce que je
trouve l'énergie de lancer toujours des
projets des défis ce genre de choses
alors je vous donnais 5 points ce sera
toujours le cas dans l'eau avec life
pour avoir une vraie motivation être
capable de faire des choses au quotidien
personnellement je suis plutôt un
procrastine heures je sais ça se voit
pas mais au fond de moi je sais que je
suis un bon branleur la première chose
que je peux vous recommander c'est
quelque chose qui marche et qui est
efficace c'est de se lever lors de son
premier réveil quand votre réveil sonne
asseyez-vous tout de suite sur votre lit
ou mieux au bord du lit et vraiment je
déconne pas même si vous pouvez chanter
ou dire quelque chose
essayez d'enclencher la machine
directement ça sert à rien de laisser 5
réveil 9 réveil du réveil vous attendrez
toujours le réveil qui fera que vous
êtes en bonne état de repos pour vous
lever je vais vous le dire il arrivera
jamais se réveille là il n'y aura pas un
matin vous allez faire art.l réveillère
ce décès aux fonctions en pleine forme
ça n'arrive pas c'est toujours
douloureux la veille et vous allez voir
vous allez démarrer la journée plus
facilement et en plus de ça vous serez
fiers de la deuxième chose c'est de
faire les choses petit à petit ça sert à
rien de vous donner une tonne de choses
à faire pour la journée c'est trop
ambitieux
ça ça fait peur de s'y mettre on sait
pas par où commencer donc organisé vous
peut-être vous allez noter sur un papier
vous avez le principe des to do list
dont je vous avais parlé et vous dites
bon dans un premier temps aujourd'hui je
j'ai pour mission de ranger au moins ma
chambre où mon bureau ou ma cuisine ou
ce que vous voulez faire les choses
petit à petit ça veut dire qu'à chaque
fois que vous réussissez quelque chose
vous avez un sentiment de réussite en
est le cerveau qui lâche une récompense
et surtout vous voyez vous avancez ça
aussi c'est cool
il vaut mieux séquencé par étapes que
d'essayer de globaliser sur un terme
générique trouver toutes les étapes et
réaliser les unes par une petit à petit
et du coup on vient au troisième élément
j'ai un peu grillé qui est de faire des
to do list
c'est très bon contre la procrastination
j'en avais parlé une fois en début
d'année dernière une to do list c'est
juste noter les choses que vous avez à
faire
au global un que ce soit pour
aujourd'hui ou dans l'absolu toutes les
choses que vous avez à faire noter les
décharger vous mentalement
une fois qu on note les choses qu'on a à
faire on se sent déjà plus libres comme
si on les avait fait baisser juste parce
que vous savez où vous en êtes et je
vous recommande aussi de les faire sur
papier plutôt que sur une application
parce que ça permet de rayer de le voir
c'est plus intéressant là quand ces
matériels que quand c'est l'électronique
après chacun fait ce qu est la quatrième
chose c'est concernant les pauses c'est
important de faire des pauses c'est pas
grave de faire une pause c'est pas grave
depuis avoir envie il vaut mieux
s'arrêter quand on est plus productif
plutôt que d'essayer de continuer dans
la souffrance est en fait de rien faire
de plus sa part avoir perdu deux heures
pour pas grand chose c'est à dire que
quand on n'a pas envie de bosser par
exemple on va faire deux heures ce qu'on
aurait fait en une demi heure quand on
avait envie de le faire faut savoir
identifier les moments aussi on va
s'arrêter ou s'arrêter ou changer
d'activité
mais si vous vous arrêtez il faut que ce
soit une vraie décision s'est il ya un
an
là maintenant j'arrête et je prends 20
minutes pour faire ça pour lire 20 min
pour regarder la télé 20 minutes pour
jouer sur mon téléphone mais c'est vous
qui devait décider ça et pas vous
laisser avoir à subir c'est ce qui fait
que sinon on reste comme ça durant des
heures dans son canapé à dire allez je
me mets là bon allez à la demie je me
mets bon allez dans une heure je me mets
en fait on s'y remet jamais vous devez
décider être maître du temps qui passe
est maître de votre temps donc vous
pouvez ne rien faire vous pouvez faire
des pauses mais il faut que ce soit une
décision de votre part et la cinquième
chose que j'ai déjà pu aborder de près
ou de loin mais là qui est important
pour cette vidéo c'est le pouvoir
de la deadline la deadline c'est le
pouvoir ultime vous l'avez vu je suis en
train de le faire a non je suis en train
de vous griller un truc en train de
faire une vidéo spéciale en ce moment où
je ne veux dire quelque chose
et j'allais le répéter mais non mais je
ne dis rien vous serez ça le 31 janvier
enfin bon quoi c'est du teasing pas du
tout ça fonctionne très bien puisqu'il
ya des gens qui travaillent un peu dans
l'urgence je suis un petit peu comme ça
c'est à dire que plus la deadline et
avance et plus on s'y met s'il n'y a pas
de deadline ya toujours une bonne excuse
pour reporter c'est pour ça que
peut-être y en a qui entre vous pensent
depuis longtemps à faire des vidéos ou à
écrire un bouquin ou à faire ceci à
faire cela et vous ne mettez pas encore
en place
parce que vous n'êtes pas imposer une
deadline ce qui est formidable c'est de
se donner une deadline d'en parler
publiquement aux personnes qui nous
entourent parce que ça met une espèce de
pression mais c'est une pression saine
alors après si vous associez la to do
list et la deadline vous pouvez m'aider
deadline dans la deadline est séquencée
tout ça avec le principe de faire les
choses également petit à petit en
parlant de faire les choses petit à
petit je vous mets un lien dans la
description vers un bouquin qui reprend
tout ce principe là de faire les choses
petit à petit et très très intéressant
ce format là est un petit peu plus court
volontairement ça me permettra d'en
sortir plus souvent quand je suis entre
deux vidéos un petit peu plus grosse
comme ça va être le cas là pour le
retour du mental expérience je pense que
cette année on va être rapidement un
rythme de 3 vidéos par semaine voire
plus de temps en temps je vous ai donné
moi les cinq points qui me paraissent
essentiels pour se motiver comme ça au
quotidien mais vous aussi vous avez
sûrement des astuces n'hésitez pas à les
mettre dans les commentaires et à réagir
là-dessus entre vous je trouve ça
toujours intéressant que l'espace
commentaire sur un espace des changes
pour vous pour compléter en fait les
astuces que je donne n'hésitez pas à
vous en servir c'est chez vous c'est à
vous concernant le spectacle pour
l'instant c'est ouf vous êtes partout
ses complices étaient complets à saint
galmier c'est la complet ce soir à
villars set complet demain et
après demain à vienne il reste encore
quelques places pour brignoles aix en
provence la semaine prochaine sinon le
mois prochain je serai également à
toulon pour quelques dates également à
versailles à la rolls factory et durant
quinze jours à grenoble à la basse cour
et plein d'autres villes jusqu'au mois
de juin vous avez comme d'habitude
toutes les dates de tournée dans la
description crois qu'il est l'heure
d'aller prendre des médicaments parce
que ça doit se voir mais vraiment j'ai
une sale gueule je suis malade je joue
avec de la fièvre sur scène c'est chiant
bref si la vidéo vous a plu comme
d'habitude n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
et de lalique et et rendez vous très
bientôt mais là c'est très très vite
très très très vite
ciao
[Musique]